on fait le point ce matin avec notre
correspondant à Kiev Gulliver crack
bonjour Gulliver les forces ukrainiennes
se préparent donc pour la bataille de la
région de Donetsk
oui mais le problème c'est que une
partie de cette participation est sous
forme de soldats ukrainien qui se forme
à l'étranger de à l'utilisation d'armes
donnés par les Alliés occidentales de
l'Ukraine à l'étranger ou ailleurs loin
de la ligne de front l'Ukraine commence
vraiment à épuiser son stock d'armes et
de munitions soviétiques son propre
stock et celle qui lui ont été donnés
par différents pays et il faut vraiment
que les armes occidentales arrivent et
aussi que les soldats Ukrainiens soient
capables de les utiliser mais vous
comprenez bien qu'avec des pertes en
blessées et ont tué de plusieurs
centaines de soldats par jour il y a eu
aussi des soldats nouvellement formés
qui ne sont plus capables d'utiliser ces
armes alors l'urgence est vraiment très
grande pour l'Ukraine de renouveler et
de se réarmer de son propre aveu le
retrait de les sitchante que la dernière
ville de la région de luance que
l'Ukraine contrôlée pendant le weekend
était dû à la supériorité de
l'artillerie russe pour le moment les
Ukrainiens sont vraiment dans une
situation assez difficile et même si le
président volody mirzelinski assure que
l'arrivée des armes modernes
occidentales permettra à l'Ukraine non
seulement de défendre le reste de la
région de Donetsk mais aussi de
reprendre la région de Lens et le sud de
l'Ukraine actuellement
occupé par la Russie il est clair que
les Russes essaient de presser
l'avantage qu'ils ont en ce moment en
termes d'armes et d'avancer au plus vite
mais bien sûr les Russes subissent aussi
des pertes très importantes Gulliver oui
on a compris l'offensive rue centre dans
une nouvelle phase que sait-on des
derniers développements de la nuit
alors les sirènes ont retentit à travers
toute l'Ukraine pendant la nuit c'était
vers 3h du matin heure locale c'est
quelque chose qui arrive très souvent
parce que quand la Russie envoie des
missiles guidées de loin souvent tirés
depuis des avions par exemple au-dessus
de la mer Noire ou de la mer Caspienne
alors les Ukrainiens ne savent pas vers
où se dirige ces missiles et donc les
sirènes retentissent sur tout le pays
d'après les informations que nous avons
ce matin c'est sur la région de ni pro
petrovsk que ces missiles ont été tirés
le gouverneur de la région affirme que 6
sur 7 missiles envoyés par la Russie ont
été abattus par les systèmes de défense
anti-aérienne
ukrainienne mais que un missile a
atteint son cible dans la ville de
pockrov qui est dans le sud de la région
Anthony pro Petros que près de la ligne
de front qui est au nord de la région de
Herson on ne sait pas encore s'il y a
des morts ou des blessés suite à cette
attaque